in Las Vegas called making it the hard
way coordinate the papers last week it's
a lot harder than we think there's one
fellow in this town who continually
makes making it the hard way seem easy
suffers from an old theatrical disease
that's very rare called total Talent mr.
Sammy Davis jr.
[Music]
thank you very much I would like at this
time to present the scoring Awards alive
what we've already had a Jimmy Stewart
impression
who did Jimmy Stewart well I never
really thought he did it too well anyway
but in that case alright to Marseille
now listen we understand I want to have
you know something like now I'm gonna
present this award
Edward G comes out next well ladies and
gentlemen I would like to sincerely say
that it's really one of the great
[Applause]
the nominees for the best music score
adaptation or treatment are John Green
for Bye Bye Birdie Andre Previn for
Amell adduce Lee Stevens for a new kind
of love Maurice Jerrod for Sunday's in
Sibel and George Brown for the sword in
the stone
and the winner is John Addison for Tom
Jones
[Applause]
oh they gave me the wrong envelope way
to the n-double a-c-p hears about this
[Applause]
make no mistake this time the winner is
Andre Previn for analogous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's always a great pleasure to work for
mr. Wilder mr. diamond and I thank them
I'm very grateful to the orchestra who
played my scores so beautifully and most
of all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for the best music score
substantially original are Alec North
for Cleopatra Demetri champion 55 days
of the King Alfred Newman Ken Davi for
How the West was won
Ernest gold for it's a mad mad mad mad
world and John Addison when Tom Jones
guess who the winner is
[Applause]
excepting for John Addison Elmer
Bernstein
[Applause]
it is my very great pleasure to join my
colleague John Madison in thanking you
very much for honoring his music but Tom
Jones thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]